to Holland who was forbidden by don
rumsfeld in the neoconservatives to
bring with him any iraq experts and so
mr. Bremer tried to run Iraq in English
and frankly I mean it's very confident
man in his own areas of expertise i
think 25-year veteran in the State
Department it he later joined Henry
Kissinger's risk management firm not
another intelligent person but it didn't
have the slightest idea of what Iraq was
and even early in his time as Viceroy he
went up to visit the curse and there was
this big portrait of a big Kurdish
leader of money and this walrus mustache
and River said well that's a handsome
gentleman who is that it was most of our
zoning I mean this would like be like if
the United States invaded Cuba over to
its government and send somebody to run
it and the guy said well that's that's
that man with the cigar there you know
cuts a dashing figure would that be you
know this is the same order of ignorance
and
and I've never had no idea who study was
either so Brenner says that he announces
that he's going to appoint a committee
to write the Iraqi Constitution and he
thinks he's General MacArthur and and so
Sistani issued him a photo op and he
critiqued this plan to a point to
constitution see study said that in this
plan there is no guarantee that the
American appointed Constituent Assembly
quote will craft the Constitution that
conforms with the highest interests of
the Iraqi people and would express this
national identity or basis of which is
pure Islamic religion and nobles social
values he then went on to say that a
constitutional assembly should be
elected that would draft the
Constitution which then would be
subjected to a popular referendum
sistani clearly held that the Iraqi
nation fe had to express its
constitutional will through voting both
for the members of the Constituent
Assembly and in a referendum on the
final constitution now I'm will argue to
you that Sistani has brought into his
juris prudence the entire enlightenment
and that
he is arguing for a social contract in
the will of the people this is shaped
jean-jacques Rousseau and I a person
which diet can can do these things if he
thinks that something is compatible with
its compatible but I am I maintain that
this is the beginning of what ah Sofia
is called post aslam ism I think there
was a big kind of mental roadblock for
the middle east before Muslim thinkers
Indian life and the question of popular
sovereignty and I remember this in the
newspapers and I'd like to try to have
the quote but I remember that people
wanted home may need to call it the
Democratic Islamic Republic of Iran and
how meny said he won't do that and that
if 37 million year on ian's as they were
then said why and the Imam said Z then
who would be right so Romanian did it
except popular son I think she's thought
he does and I think this kind of
statement that he gave to Brevard shows
it and there are newspaper articles from
his colleagues he castigated the interim
Governing Council of Iraq which was in
Rocky's will play by River for trying to
legislate on issues he said that it
didn't especially since it lacks
legitimacy soon as since it is not
received the ceiling approval from the
note
authority on Marge a genious Reba and
has not received the approval of the
people via a general election so see
study is saying that there are two
sources of legitimacy was that Jeff has
to sign off on it but the other is other
people have to have to have their say
and then a the brother of the Iraqi
government in the American government in
rock collapsed by my October of 2003 the
country was an insurgency and bombs were
going off and nobody would pay attention
brebre one point called the council
together then hit appointed so okay I
was time to write the Constitution and
they said oh no we can't do that and he
said well why ever not they said well
there's a fence one against dead so
remember according to enter the late
anthony shadid said could we get a foot
from some other Bolong River didn't
understand it the hierarchy and can't
like just overruled sistani so a river
flows back to Washington and Ford was
conjure Ison george w bush so the whole
thing is collapsed and they have to do
something else so they decide to put any
rocky face on it and that
to elect an elected government but their
idea of elected government was friends
of George they had massaged into paying
these provincial councils in this
provinces of Iran and they said the
provincial councils we let the
Parliament which that we elect a prime
minister so the elector would be the
Iraqi notables who had already announced
that they're willing to collaborate with
Americans and boy vs. tiny man in
response to the questions of anthony
shadid of the washington post he gave
his most explicit but yeah responding
two brothers council based plan you said
the instrumentality and visitors tinted
for electing the members of the
transitional legislature does not
guarantee the formation of a parliament
that truly represents the Iraqi people
it must be changed to some other method
which would guarantee it and that is
direct election such that the Parliament
would derive from the will of the Iraqis
and we represent them in a just manner
and will safeguard it from any challenge
to its legitimacy this is what he says
in Arabic a little foolish I am above
the Covenant errata to Shabbat Iraqi
legitimate government derives from the
will of the Iraqi people so I I really I
can't find anything
that is GI sources this is really a
departure it's this open unqualified
embrace of the idea of popular
sovereignty it is really quite
remarkable and I think a big turning
point um no I mean there are these other
sources where you know what would be the
rule of that Jeff in all this is that
they would affect was they would
persuade the Muslims to do the right
thing they would they would intervene
and I made an analogy that you know back
in the early 20th century gates
complained that like when the Irani the
Irish parliament considered whether to
have divorce or not the Irish Catholic
higher intervened and said no and part
of it folded at that time and gates
mysterious but that's the kind of that's
the kind of system that I think that
that ceased on is advocating
be one where it is popular sovereignty
there's democracy there's an elected
parliament if an issue came up that
affected Islamic society the Najaf would
defect Elizabeth politic and would try
to intervene to try to get cajole
department and doing my thing but not
through a dictatorship not tuition
issuing an order and just to say that
Switzerland Bush administration seemed
as though it might pay no attention to
cease Donny he arranged for
demonstrations first in Basra and that
in Baghdad these were the largest
demonstrations held in Iran since the
great communist demonstrations of 1959
that against the possible government
refusal to involve dymonus nothing this
big had happened in you walk in the
meantime and the Bush administration
neatly folded and said yes yes we'll
have elections and of course see spotty
arranged for for the Shiites to gather
together to one part and they won those
elections in 2005 but I see this very
complex interaction of the arrow die
jurisprudence and the consideration of
what is the role of the 50
the jurisprudence in in the system with
a very interesting set of aridity is
around popular sovereignty of the
Enlightenment and modern nationalism in
which i think see study really has been
some pioneering work in now yeah I see
evidence of it and nobody will admit it
but I think when you read of some of the
statements of the Muslim Brotherhood in
Egypt they followed all of those
controversies and I think they may be
also a little bit they won't it but
there might be a little bit influenced
by by some of these ideas as you study
they went to atribute them all to
everyone turkey so i'll leave it there